this thing's gonna come crumbling down
that's what I've said q q why didn't you
hire me you could have hired me and a
half ago wow I wanted this job do not
Finance your furniture Caleb absolutely
Finance your furniture no you don't do
that how much you bring it in per month
on YouTube
all right Mr Caleb Hammer you said
something about 15 million dollars what
was that okay all right we're getting
right into it well I just feel like that
when you're
all right yeah you're hitting strong yep
let's hear about it 15 million dollars I
feel like if you have 15 million dollars
in stocks and you withdraw four percent
which I know three percent is more long
battery better but four percent was the
quick math 50 million dollars in the
stock market fifty thousand dollars a
month that's fifty thousand dollars a
month yeah it's fifty thousand dollars a
month I feel like that's an amazing if
you're in a very good income situation
of which I've become absolutely blessed
to be in because I have the most amazing
audience in the world it's like if
I'm like 1 15th of the way there if
someday I get there I feel like that's
incredible because how can you even
spend 50 000 hours a month I have no
idea you'll find a way in Texas you'll
find a way it's a bigger house bigger
property taxes aquariums that's a Tesla
there's a lot of ways to spend it goes
fast I just feel like it's it's like the
ultimate goal the ultimate goal you were
saying something Graham where you're
like yeah you're saying 15 now but at
some point in the future yes I think
once you build up to the point where you
get to 15 you're gonna say 20. because
what if your Stock's half in value now
that 15 turns into seven and a half what
if your 15 happens during the peak of a
bull run and then you say all right I
got my 15 I'm done you lose 50 like that
now you're down to seven and a half and
then you think well now I got to go back
to work I just think if you were given
15 million today and snap at the Hat
done you might treat a little
differently than if you accumulate 15
million over let's just say a decade I
will say I'm very competitive with
myself so I'm sure if for some reason I
ever get there which is still just crazy
yeah that okay sure I'd be competitive
with myself I'd probably want to do more
and stuff like that but 15 just sounds
like such a milestone that is slightly
beyond what I think is possible that
it's something to just shoot the moon
for sure yeah and have you mapped out at
your current trajectory how long that's
going to take you if things continue at
the same path which we're going to get
into very shortly no how long no I
haven't because I refuse to believe that
I there's something in the back of my
head every single day that this thing is
going to come crumbly now that's what
I've said I've told Jack because it's
the very beginning like this is the last
month Jack how often have I said this is
the last time like every time we meet
exactly these jacket's over I have such
a big fear and anxiety around okay so I
have the show and the show's primary
goal is to educate the people the
financial educate the people on the show
and that educate the audience as well
and I'd be okay doing that only bringing
in
a tenth of what's bringing in I would
still love to do that it's absolutely
good because I could still sustain
myself and stuff well maybe not in the
new house but you know liquidate that
move into like a place that I was at
before and that'd be totally fine I just
have a fear anxiety man we just live
in this age where like anything online
can happen one random person gets angry
at you for yelling I'm someone who yells
I'm gonna show it happens I like the
yelling though 462 dollars of purchases
what are we doing do it in the future
well it's also just my personality it's
part of the show it's my personality but
I yell at someone just the wrong way
then boom I'm the most evil person
that's ever been created on the history
of the planet and it's time for Caleb
Hammer's overparty and it's just like
okay I feel like that's always a
preparation yeah but how much of a
service is it providing for you to
constantly be worried and anxious about
something like that but it's on the back
of my head at all times it's like
because anyone can do anything anyone
can spread anything this is the internet
is a weird place where people don't care
about other people's feelings because
someone's behind a camera they're all
sudden a person that no longer exists
they are not just a normal person
anymore it's weird but see you can't
control that you could only control
yourself and so when you can control
yourself you can control what you do
with those emotions what you do with
your time what you choose to focus on
and if you're focused on that we're
focused on the things that bring you
anxiety and we're talking about you
feeling trapped when we're filming for
your episode of you feeling like you're
not in control and I think at a certain
point I'm very much the same way I like
being in control of things you just have
to let it go I've been getting better at
that too uh I've been very hands on with
everything I've done but there is a
sense of relief that comes with I can't
control it nothing I could do let the
anxiety go yeah it's fair enough which
is we've we've all seen people on
Twitter just just go wild and just
follow down any rabbit hole and so I
think that's just always just in the
back of my head because I never expected
to be in this position I hardly want to
be in this position I know someone's
gonna say okay but you're making a ton
of money sure that's great but you know
I have to say your come up has been
faster than just about any other Finance
channel that I've seen right yeah in
finance I don't think there's anyone
that's gone from like relatively unheard
of a year ago to where you are today
when I'm posting hey I'm in Austin who
should we do a podcast with it was Joe
Rogan was number one you were the second
and I'm not sure if that's just because
her audience is overlap which I have a
feeling is a lot of it oh yeah but
there's so many people that said Caleb
the fact that you went from almost
nothing a year ago to that today really
says a lot about what you're doing and I
think that's a lot for people to handle
coming up with such a consistent
schedule like you do
and growing at that speed people have
just been so cool and so supportive it's
been really cool well I mean I was
telling you off camera and I'll tell you
now I don't think it's anything that a
YouTuber should say but I like being
open and transparent sure and I was
telling you this off camera I actually
don't really like being a YouTuber I
really don't I feel like it's a lot of
kids dreams but I don't it gives me
panic attacks almost on a daily basis at
night I go to bed with panic attacks I
wake up with panic attacks it's just so
much stress there's so much I like the
interaction so every once in a while
yeah um I'll you know run into someone
on the street like oh kill Hammer stuff
like that and that's cool that's a
positive good interaction but even that
I'm like nervous in some specific
instances like what if I just went out
in my pajamas that day and then all of a
sudden like you know someone recognizes
me and it's just like a baton
oh I love that I love when I'm dressed
like crap and I'm at Target and I'm
doing the ultimate I'm doing the
ultimate sin which is wearing socks with
sandals and I do that just dress
horrible I'm walking in so I was like
Graham and I'm like yeah I'm shopping at
the cheap part of Target like the
clearance section it's not it's a it's
it's what you would expect if you see me
in person I'm usually dressed pretty bad
just wearing just you know free clothing
I love running the business side of
things I love running business you know
my dad's a business owner my grandpa had
a small business my Grandma had a corner
shop I think that just runs in my blood
love working with the employees that
I've brought on full-time love that I
hate how public this job is
hate it but you're good at it you're
great on camera so that's why that 15
exists if I ever got that I think if I
hit that number I think all of a sudden
no one would ever hear from me again
I would disagree I would disagree with
that I think you're too good at what you
do and the demand is there and enough
people have an interest in your content
I think you could take it so many places
yeah I think the thing that gives me the
panic attacks the most is just the wide
audience this is such a big number now
people rely on me I have two people who
they rely on me to pay their rent they
really like me to pay their bills and
then I've you know taken on bills of my
own and then also I mean there can be
people who disagree with how the way I
do the show you know maybe they wouldn't
get financial help being in the seat
right you know maybe it's not for them
but then it's like character
assassinations and stuff like that
things that people
they just they go to this extent and say
you're someone completely different than
you are and that gets under my skin if
it's with me where they think I have
negative intentions because I might
raise my voice every once in a while I'm
betting that you're gonna get over it
eventually I don't know how soon or how
late it will be but I think that right
now you're so focused and you say that
all of your anxiety comes from this wide
audience that you have no I think it
just comes from an underlying condition
of being an anxious person definitely am
and once you solve that having a wide
audience and people that complain about
you online and make hate videos and
stuff like that like that's not going to
affect you I don't agree I don't care
about complaints I don't care about
complaints or hate videos specifically
is when people character assassinate
that's what I don't like when they turn
you into someone all of your anxiety to
this up here when actually it's just
this underlying condition of being an
anxious person right yeah and eventually
you're going to solve this which is
going to solve all these auxiliary
things yeah great book The subtle art of
not giving a
okay I read that a couple months ago
yeah it's good yeah there's an audiobook
by the way for free I think on YouTube
so you could just listen to it the book
is actually better because I feel like
you internalize it more a great book I'd
recommend that this feels like a Caleb
Hammer event session so far we'll get
more into the venting yeah but the
reason about one more thing is it in and
out no okay go ahead
it's you
you why didn't you hire me you
could have hired me a year and a half
ago wow I wanted this job what was the
job for I don't know any job this was to
do Jack's laundry was it actually yes
anything I would have done anything I
wanted a change in job I had enough
saved up so here's what happened uh two
and a half years ago give or take this
was Alex's position yep yeah we Caleb
was right there so we asked our audience
to submit a video on YouTube Just title
it Graham Stefan interview and in the
interview we want you to share why you
think that we should hire you and we
looked through all the videos we
probably got 100 submissions we're
sending submissions but Caleb I think
you were you were saying you wanted you
wanted to make one of those videos but
you decided against it and instead you
went with a financial audit approach
because you're gonna film a video well
yeah you already hired him so yeah like
a year and a half ago and I was done I
got turned down by another YouTuber and
stuff and I was like damn but I want to
work in the YouTube space and like you
know uh wash you forever try to get in
your DMs no looks all right no I totally
get it no I get a trillion DMS a day now
so I I get not being able to look at
them so that makes sense and then you
also did not look uh I don't check them
Alex also did not look uh but I I scored
a one-on-one with him I paid for a
one-on-one with him and I talked to him
and I was like okay
can I get a job for like zero dollars
like I'll come work for free because I
just want to work in the YouTube space
yeah
um and the answer was no and that was
totally fine but I was like you know I'm
gonna show that I know Graham's script
style I know Graham's video style
editing blah blah so I ordered like
everything of your set so I could redo
the Set uh film write a script and even
do like the gram talking arms and
everything yeah
um and record that send it to you guys
somehow and then maybe get a job less uh
last attempt ditch right there okay and
then I just decided to uh record make a
show that I wish I was able to watch
that's good what were you doing before
then I because I noticed Caleb Hammer
composer so you're into music oh yeah
well yeah I mean that's always been a
side hustle and I studied music
composition in college and dropped out
actually I dropped out of college uh but
what I was doing right before that a
little naughty never talked about it
before I was doing the classic work from
homework two jobs but you know what
before we go into that we have a bonus
segment really quick Jack sent me a few
of his expenses and I have to say it's
atrocious because everything is
completely disorganized but Grim I have
so many different softwares and plugins
that I need to subscribe to to run my
business I mean what do you recommend I
do the thing is running a business could
be tough and try to manage that with a
whole bunch of different softwares could
be really confusing but that's why our
sponsor netsuite wants to help all you
have to do is remember three numbers
thirty six thousand twenty five and one
thirty six thousand because thirty six
thousand companies have already upgraded
the netsuite that means they stopped
doing things like typing in data by hand
and searching through scattered numbers
25 because netsuite has spent 25 years
helping businesses drive down their cost
and one because netsuite is an
all-in-one solution that allows you to
manage all of your kpis or key
performance indicators with one
efficient system you know what Graham
you're right netsui can help reduce
mistakes for manual data entry which
there always are and prevent your busy
work from scaling with the business so
get a full picture of your business and
help make better decisions faster make
sure to download netsuite's popular kpis
checklist for free right now at
netsuite.com iced again that's
netsuite.com ice to get your own kpi
checklist for free netsuite.com iced
with the link Down Below in the
description thank you so much and now
let's get to the episode so you had a
full-time job and then you were also
doing something on the side that they
didn't know I had two full-time jobs in
non-competitive non-competitive
businesses they didn't know that no and
I talked to a lawyer before this because
I wanted to make sure I had them read
through the employment contracts of both
uh companies nothing is against this
that they could take action of now
because one I don't work for either of
them two they weren't competitive
businesses and I didn't do anything that
overlapped with each other in terms of
different work projects on either but
yeah I worked one job in another job and
I had half the time blocked off as uh
busy on each calendar and just had like
thousand hours of meetings and then I
got laid off from one of the jobs fairly
enough because I was doing and also
I was done with that company because
that company and I'm not gonna say who
though yeah and they're just they
weren't very good and they're going
downhill but whatever
and then I stuck with the other job for
a little bit but then YouTube started
taking off and so I ended up quitting
that so what did you do out of college
then if you dropped out why did you drop
out of school I dropped out and it
wasn't this was not a financial smart
decision and this was like what seven
years ago or something like that
um I dropped out study music composition
this is gonna make me sound like the
biggest in the world but this
was like my actual logic not was not
trying to brag I was making more money
selling my music compositions than my
professors were so I was like I didn't
even know you did that much like an
extra 20 000 a year it's nothing crazy
selling your own music company so yeah
right actual music so like me like in
the concert band world like people will
pay you like a certain uh number per
minute of music that you write
in like an original piece and then
people will then purchase that music
eventually once it's published so you
play the piano or what is it that you I
played the trombone a little bit of the
bassoon I can fake the piano more like
chords yeah Melody but I then I write
music like that yeah how did you get
started doing that were you always just
gifted in music dude I
oh it was random
fourth grade
we had a music class that everyone hates
no one likes elementary school music
class so I think I did you did yeah you
liked playing the recorder we never we
never did that no I was involved in like
the piano and stuff oh okay uh either
way we would have like every once in a
while we'd go to the computer we'd take
like music theory or whatever I you know
but the quicker you complete the
assignment you can go into a program
where you drag notes onto a thing and it
makes you know songs and stuff and then
I was like I asked for that for
Christmas that program and that's what I
ended up getting and I just you know
fell into the love of just writing music
and coming up with music and the idea
was like okay there's a piece of music I
want to hear it doesn't exist yet so I'm
gonna write that piece of music so
you're making music making about what
20K I hear you said extra something like
that what period of time in your life
was this during college this was during
college yeah okay so then you dropped
out of college yeah right and then
immediately after college you got this
product management not immediately no I
was just working around doing extra jobs
barely making a buy buy the music
composition Stuff Plus Jimmy Johnson
some other odd jobs and stuff like that
but then I ended up getting a sales job
down in Austin uh five years ago because
one of my uh friends that I've known
forever he just recently graduated
college he ended up getting a sales job
down here and they were looking for the
exact same position and I was like oh
okay well there you go I've always
wanted to be in Austin so perfect pack
up the sedan come down in a week and
then uh just kind of built a mini career
at that company but I was able to do
very well in sales so that was home
uh it was like education when it comes
to trading and different things you can
plug into your charts to help trade okay
so like indicators and stuff like that
so we're selling educational classes for
trading trading indicators and
subscription Services uh to watch
Traders trade live and then so the sales
team was responsible for getting people
into those so it wasn't much cold
calling because we didn't have a big
team so really we only had time to focus
on the people who are already internal
and it was actually quite an easy job I
always led the sales team which was a
very big prideful thing for me uh except
for my first month obviously when I
didn't know I was on so I ended up
leading the sales team and that's how I
paid off all my debt as quick as
possible before then a couple years
before then was when I started to get
really interested in the personal
finance and becoming as educated as I
could on that and then Landing you know
the first adult job it was like the
perfect Avenue that sales as much as you
grind as smart as you are in it you can
make it in a different uh like an
infinite amount of money as long as the
company doesn't suck right so I just
worked my ass off and made as much money
in that role as possible to pay off the
debt start investing and then save up uh
10 down payment on my first property all
within a couple years and how much are
we making doing sales over a hundred
you're making over 100 from that yeah
even though the base salary is 30. but
what about that other job that you were
also working well that was only the last
six months got it okay uh the last three
three four months at this original
company yeah so I was doing a product
management role of both the companies
and then got laid off at the first one
totally fair reasonable I wanted to quit
anyway I was just like all right may as
well collect the Dual income over here
which I mean come on not a good thing to
do I don't recommend anyone do it like I
don't feel great about it but it
happened and I'm open and honest yeah
it's not something I would say anyone
should do but yeah what led you down
personal finance at that time oh it was
way before man I've always been
interested in real estate I don't know
if it was growing up as an HGTV kid I'm
not sure but like
just delivering Jimmy John's to uh all
throughout College I actually delivered
to a lot of the rental property
management companies and I just became
really interested in that just you know
uh bigger pocket type material Bigger
Pockets yeah I got really into that
reading the books audiobooks whatever
and I started getting into real estate
that way and then real estate I feel is
a good natural overlap and just just the
world of personal finance and wanting
then I think that was more like Dave
Ramsey started hearing some of him and
like oh A lot of people are in a
bad situation like I'm oh my Situation's
bad
maybe I should do something about it
yeah then you know actually work to do
something about it and sacrifice I feel
like real estate is extremely appealing
because it seems like the most hands-off
you can be while making passive income
whereas like the other things that
appeal to the younger generation such as
like trading and stuff like that that's
like okay you have to have some level of
expertise in trading and it's more
active income although it could get you
rich quicker but real estate's like okay
you can build wealth over time which is
still exciting but it's also extremely
hands-off where you're like okay
especially if you're working with a
brokerage yeah or a rental property
management company because yours is
pretty Hands-On right uh not more yeah
it was when I was actively involved in
it oh my gosh I was going to those
around but I was also doing renovations
and I was there every day sometimes
twice a day yeah no that's just keeping
an eye on what about that yeah I
couldn't stand it and I mean at the time
I enjoyed it but yeah I have four
tenants that rent rooms in my house but
they're basically your pals right yeah
they're they're just my friends but at
the same time like just owning a house
like stuff will go wrong so for example
like there was raining like for a whole
week in Vegas and now we have just seen
them shroom yeah we have a mushroom
so that's getting inspected right now I
had some of my floorboards uh they were
leaking water water was seeping from
beneath the floorboards uh so getting
that checked out as well uh just like
other random homeowners they ever find
out what was wrong with your wall our
patio cover it's bolted into the to the
wall and then the bolts were not sealed
properly so when the rain came it ran
down the facade of the house into where
the uh the connection point was and then
that went in between the wall and then
it went down to the floor and then out
comes a mushroom
well it's a that's a long ways for the
water to go I would be worried about the
damage all the way down all the way down
yeah well I mean we're gonna open up the
wall and get it all checked out but the
water all settled at the bottom so like
that's where you know the moisture was
detected when we used a moisture meter
you could always just be an idiot and go
buy a brand new house I could do that
yeah at the rates that we have right now
oh yeah you just did and we'll also get
into that but anyways that is the
Grievances that I have with
homeownership but it's a beautiful thing
so I think it's important why did you
quit your hundred thousand dollar a year
job to do YouTube uh well I quit it once
uh we're at 10 000 a month and I was
doing all the work myself so I got all
the money so that kind of equated to it
and I made sure I saved up a one-year
emergency fund before I went into it
because I think business owners should
have probably one year emergency fund
honestly again I I do not want to just
say this over and over again and let it
lose weight like okay sure I'm sure I do
an okay job on the show literally every
Thanks goes to the guests who come on
the show because there wouldn't be there
wouldn't be a show if people weren't
willing to come on and put the front
situation in display and like for the
whole world to learn off of so thank you
to them and then thank you to the
audience this is not something I could
have ever even dreamed of does it feel
fake or real it feels fake oh it feels
completely fake yeah like I mean I've
the only thing I've upgraded in my life
is a house and it was an expensive house
I needed more space but that you you
know how's the furniture
do not Finance your furniture Caleb
absolutely Finance your furniture no you
don't do that you do not finance
department
I like zero percent Finance when it's a
finance how much was the furniture I
think into well I zero percent uh
Finance the uh all of it back there okay
so how much was that you finance
something thirty thousand maybe with the
TV sound system uh couch chair rugs uh
the guest bedroom stuff so all the
furniture I bought for this entire Place
probably thirty thousand dollars
including some of the staging furniture
but isn't it like cumbersome to go in
like Auto like not auto pay but like pay
that and then you're coming
on a credit check on you on that they
must right yeah I think so
no I don't know
it's not cumbersome so it happens on a
monthly basis I make sure I always have
fifty thousand dollars in my checking
account if I always have fifty thousand
dollars in my checking account plus a
one year emergency fund on the side then
when that happens it happens it hits
your account it's gone in six months and
I invested that what did I say thirty
thousand dollars instead and guess what
since I invested it the stock market has
been great this year I've made a great
return on that investment instead of
could have just as easily gone down
though you could have invested that
money
to be honest hindsight is great it would
have been in though and it would have
grown historically what
you right what you did is objectively
smart I'm just honestly I'm astonished
you did that right it's something I
advocate for on the show but not for
most people people who just have clearly
demonstrated that they are bad with
money exactly I think if you can if you
can finesse money I love finessing and
love taking the extra mental effort to
just go wild for an extra point five
percent that's okay because I can manage
it for the average person I don't think
it's a thing just like a credit card
it's not good for the average person I
don't think a car loan is good for the
average person but I think if I have
twenty thousand dollars and I'm gonna go
buy a 20 000 car and I can get a rate at
three percent on the car I'd rather put
a thousand dollars down on the car get
it at three percent throw that other
nineteen thousand dollars in the stock
market I think there's a level where it
just becomes trivial and it becomes not
even worth your time anymore you're
right I think for me it's more fun
I like finessing it because it's fun
it's a game finances in the end if
you're doing it well regardless of the
income that has been blessings but even
when you know I was making 100 000 hours
to when I was making fifty thousand
dollars so when I was making thirty
thousand dollars a lot of the stuff
finding the best deals and stuff like
that if that's something you're into it
can be fun it's like a video game so I
think that's one reason I went about it
but before we go into that if you guys
have been following us or Caleb hammer
for a while you may have noticed over
the course of the last couple of years
our production quality has drastically
improved and if a financial audit was
done on either of us at that time it
would not look pretty well thankfully
stream yard is a live streaming software
that allows you to create high quality
content with just the click of a button
for the low cost of free so you're
saying like the ten thousand dollars we
put into the studio we could have just
done it for free technically yes all you
need is a camera and an internet
connection and from there you could
stream really high quality content right
from your browser plus you can stream to
multiple social media platforms at the
same time including Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn and more plus guys they have so
many other amazing features that we
haven't mentioned yet like they have
analytics tools that tell you where all
of the traffic is coming from we highly
recommend you guys check out streamyard
it's completely free check it out with
that link Down Below in the description
honestly guys stream yard is one of the
best ways that you could begin creating
high quality content without spending a
ton of money and one of the best ways to
start is just to start for the local
cost of free so the link is down below
in the description we highly recommend
you check it out thank you so much and
now back to the podcast we went through
you have 37 000 of student loans not
bothered paying that off for no degree
yeah for no degree that you dropped out
of school but you're trying to Arbitrage
the four percent on the student loan
that's non-tax deductible with your
investment returns in the stock market
historically yeah and hoping that that's
enough to cover the student loans and
make a bit of a profit because I like to
pay it off today yes and I know that
from the Savings in the side I can pay
off if I didn't have that I wouldn't
invest the other money but you learn
from experience because the people that
you have on the show you go into them
when they graduate with a whole bunch of
debt you've seen it especially private
private private debt for useless degrees
but also once I get through all their
debt usually the last thing we talk
about is any federal student loans that
are at four percent or less and then
usually for them depending on the
situation I'm like okay minimal monthly
payment sales paid off we need to catch
up on investing because you're 40 and
you don't have people sent to your name
so so I'm curious where do you find
people to be on the show well 99 comes
from the audience so is it DMS uh no no
we have a survey in our uh description
so people can fill out there so for
weirdos who think we're like taking
advantage of people no people are going
out of the way to come on the show
people are literally going out of their
way and flying multiple States because
they want to come on the show because
they know it's the method that helps
them and they want to put their
situation on display it is the exact
conversation that I wish I had at 18.
might not work for everyone yeah that's
fine it's the conversation I wish I had
because it would work for me how much
research do you do ahead of time on your
guests uh a good amount now I've been
able to so we collect our information we
put it in a spreadsheet and we see what
the who we could probably help the best
um there are good conversations that can
happen from people who've you know built
a good amount of wealth but I know
that's also taking a limited spot away
from someone who's like Caleb please I
need to be on the show I'm literally
like gonna die in debt please build me a
budget what does it take so we figure
out the people we can best help come on
the show they do that I have some
part-time
people also on the side who help put all
their stuff into spreadsheets and build
some things out with me so I can saved
me a few hours for each episode and then
I personally go through their documents
as well and how can you tell if someone
wants to be on the show just to be on
the show get some publicity versus
someone who genuinely wants help because
from what I've seen watching almost all
of your episodes some people on there
I'm like they don't give a crap they
just want to be on they want the air
time they're trying to you know get
their name out there it just seems like
you could tell them whatever they want
your excuses and then at the end I'm
like they're not going to do anything
which is where I definitely you can see
I get more irritated with them more than
other people but I know that even still
the advice that I give them in their
situation you know getting at least 200
000 views an episode It's Gonna help a
few thousand hopefully that are relating
to the situation so even if they might
not walk away with it because they're
just a little
for coming on and getting uh you know
publicity or whatever the reasoning uh
someone else is going to benefit and
what trends have you noticed amongst
people that are struggling financially
like what what are they doing with their
money why is it not going in their favor
uh everyone's good with getting a five
six seven year car loan at 25 and thinks
that that doesn't mean anything so
that's crazy I mean what the average new
car payment what was it I think it's
recently come out to like 800 a month
yeah it's insane if 50 of the people in
this in the United States 50 who have a
job make thirty thousand dollars or less
on a yearly basis 800 a month as the new
average car payment that's Insanity now
what's interesting is that when you look
into auto loans they're not regulated
the same way that student loans are or
with mortgages or even credit cards for
that matter credit card reviews your
income in such a way where they're not
going to give you too much of a limit
because that's an unsecured debt they're
not going to collect on that if you
don't pay that debt they're going to
discharge it but auto loans for the most
part very unregulated it's a very much
gray Market that they could sell these
off privately without there being you
know a rule out there that says oh we
can't qualify you for this most auto
loan places are able to give you the
loan that you want by just extending out
the term even if the interest rate's 20
25 yeah it's scary it's scary I'll also
say there are
on the show I try not to talk about a
lot of societal things because it's like
okay that's another show we can cover
what should what should not blah blah
blah and also just vote however you want
to vote that's whatever we don't get
into that my job is to say okay this is
where we live right now and this is the
best way to navigate it because it's
irresponsible for me on the side of the
table to say something different one
thing I will say societal that I like to
rant about and I'll rant about for a
second
our car infrastructure
if it's a societal text that we have in
the United States that everyone has to
have a car to survive it's so
it's so stupid unless you live in New
York City San Francisco or Chicago where
they have actually decent public
transportation you essentially have to
get a job in order to work in order to
afford the car that you're getting to
actually work it sucks man it sucks
that infuriates me well that's why I
like Dave Ramsey's approach that the car
you could afford is the one that you
could buy out right in cash or the card
that you could pay off relatively
quickly I think people are sleeping on
these sub ten thousand dollar cars you
go on Craigslist or auto trader so many
great cars out there six seven eight
thousand dollars a Toyota Corolla 100
000 miles on it it's good for another
hundred thousand miles easily very
reliable people are also it's a great
out of purchasing though so people will
get that
three four five thousand dollar car and
they won't get it you know checked out
by a mechanic to make sure that it's
going to be safe for them and it's going
to be reliable for at least a few years
to come and then it just breaks down and
it gives yeah cars within that price
category a really bad name which is very
fair I would venture to say that more
people in that category just want a
newer car oh much better about no I want
the car that's two years old it doesn't
have to pay more I'd much rather I'd be
happier in that car than this old piece
of junk over here I don't want to be
seen in that I think there's also a lot
of pressure to be seen in a nice looking
car and that's almost a reflection of
who you are as a person yeah if you see
someone pull up in an old car are people
going to judge you for that are they
going to think that maybe because you're
driving an old car here maybe you're not
as good as what you do if you're good at
what you do you should be driving a
newer car because you could afford it so
there's all these image things that I
think play into that as well I have to
say I am blessed to have the mindset
that with the income that I currently
have that you all have blessed me with
completely thanks to you thank you
I don't give a about cars so I
probably will never spend money on a car
that is way too expensive I have my 2019
Jeep Cherokee that has good sound system
and that's all I care about that's good
very lucky do you find that the people
that end up over purchasing on their
vehicle they regret it or are they still
happy about it and they think that the
the source of all their financial
problems comes from something else well
it definitely comes down to how they're
prioritizing their money in general like
the big picture in terms of where their
money is going but then yes those little
decisions that can be big decisions like
the car is definitely a big thing A lot
of people are regretting it more than
they were at the beginning of the show
because car values you know they were
great when I was first starting used car
values and though it's still not the
pre-pandemic level's not even close and
it probably never will be it has come
down a little and a lot of people who've
come in with these expensive used cars
now find that they're underwater by
thousands and thousands of thousands of
dollars so selling it is not always an
option anymore and making up that
difference with the potential person
alone or something but it's getting
harder and harder for the expensive car
loans that we have on the show to come
up with a good solution other than
so it's time to sacrifice for years I
mean what do you think that someone
should do if they're looking for a car
or they think their car might be too
expensive for their needs if it's too
expensive for their needs I mean just I
think it just comes to the overall
maturity around the purchase of it but
when it comes to the average person
looking for a car as long as we're
budgeting out we have an emergency so
the question is then okay why do they
need a new car did the car break down if
the car broke down they should have a
six month emergency fund we can at least
get a temporary measure while we then
build that up and then pay for another
car now does someone need another car
because they just want another car okay
fine then we're putting we're putting in
our wants category a certain percentage
decide on a monthly basis that is going
towards saving up a cash pile to get the
car that we want again I think some
people can Finance uh finesse low
interest car loans I do not think that
is the average person you did with your
Tesla lovely and I think that's good I
might if my jeep ever breaks down and I
can get a good rate but I think for the
average person just like cards that a
cash option is better for them and aside
from Cars what other Trends are you
finding or patterns amongst the people
that are financially struggling yeah
spending 40 percent not eating out
eating out oh yeah so it's like fast
food is like fantastic and trust me I
like my nugs everyone knows I like my
nugs but like
when people are in really bad debt but
they're only paying their minimum
monthly payments and they have student
retirement and only their minimum
monthly payments accounting for five
percent of their overall spending but
fifty percent of their spending is going
to eating out
we got some priorities that need to be
straightened out why do you think people
aren't cooking at home why do you think
they're so prone to eating out all the
time well ease of access I mean luckily
it fits in my budget now and I
definitely eat out a good amount and
what if it's in my budget a lot of the
reasons why I can speak to my own
reasons for eating out I got addictive
Tendencies towards it so when it comes
to the fatty the salty the sweet and
stuff like that that can that's honestly
my addiction Crush that just get rid of
that I know I know but the salty sweet
one is like the brain hack I think your
brain just craves that naturally and so
and they've been giving it so whenever I
take it away
it's it's really really difficult for me
now I I was able to do that when it came
to getting out of debt and saving up for
a house I was able to do that from a
financial standpoint but when I think
about my health for some reason I'm not
as motivated
and I need to be there I feel like so
many reasons why people don't take
action especially like with regards to
their finances or with regards to like
eating which is because the consequence
of the action that they take up front is
way too detached and delayed from the
action they take oh so for example when
you're eating fast food it's like you
feel great immediately but then the
consequence of eating that fast food
such as gaining a little bit of weight
or maybe feeling lethargic it's like
days down the road maybe and you can't
necessarily see like a one-to-one you
know this is my action this is the
consequence from that action and the
same thing goes for finance it's like
you know you can save a little bit of
money here but it doesn't matter if you
spend it because it's a few bucks or you
can put it on credit but then it delays
the consequence of it rather than like
when you're a kid and you say a swear
word and your dad comes up to you and
spanks you right away you're like okay
now I know I say a swear word I get
spanked not going to do that but with
food and with finances the consequence
is just so far out in the future now
yeah I know that's true and it's also
just daunting to tackle uh
you know the offset unless you're in it
already you know so losing weight
starting the diet or uh tackling a big
amount of debt you're already in this
train of just doing what you're already
doing and you know there's this big
problem it's a daunting thing to
overcome and start but once you start
it's actually much easier and then you
start seeing the progress of making it
motivates you to go even further it's
it's so similar between finance and
health though and I feel like because
you're on such the finance path that
eating healthy and going to the gym
should be so easy for you because it's
the same thing the same qualities that
lead you to saving money are the exact
same to eating something going you know
it actually might be easy for me it's
just I think it's the the daunting
starting I think if I started and I
continued down healthy sustainable
routes so I've done Extreme Cuts before
and it's resulting in good progress but
it wasn't sustainable and I bounced back
yeah I think if I head down it I'm quite
disciplined once I'm in it I think
everyone thinks they need they need to
like exit the gate sprinting and I don't
think that's the case at all I think you
could just start by introducing
healthier foods into the diet maybe
going out a little bit less but it
doesn't need to be like zero to one
hundred right good thing we all ate 10
Burgers right before this time yeah what
that what was that all about man because
we still ordered the entire menu we
showed up tasting and and you I mean you
walk in and you what how many bags 15
bags oh easily I mean like I had
probably six Burgers which I should not
be used
no you didn't have six
probably somewhere are you serious he
had to cleanse his body from all his
love
did you take
in words no but I felt like I didn't die
oh my God that's why I stopped eating I
think it is extremely important my one
piece of advice get in good shape yeah
get in good shape that's what I was
there's no excuses you have no reason
not to I know it's scary I know it's
daunting but it will be one of the most
rewarding things that you have done you
know how rewarded you feel when you help
someone out with their finances when
they come on your show and you they DM
you weeks later like hey you know what I
paid off my debt everything 26 APR like
I paid it off you will feel
dare I say just as good if not better
fixing your own health it has been for
me one of the most rewarding things I've
ever done in my entire life taking it
seriously over the past year cleaning up
my diet I feel more motivated I feel
like it's easier to get out of bed every
morning I feel like I have more energy
it's easier for me to just get started
on a task that would have taken me I
don't know like an hour to muster up the
the motivation to do beforehand it is
confidence too you feel better about
yourself oh yeah
it would get more matches then your
anxieties too and all these judgments
trust me I've been very fit and I have
the same you know what I would do is
hire a personal trainer and prepay them
looked at that I did look at that
prepaid them for like three months yeah
I looked at it before I moved in there
yeah
working out right now I would just clean
up the diet because working out is a
whole nother thing you'd have to
introduce but I think it's scary in
conjunction oh yeah oh it'll be nice I
think the benefits from working out are
just working out is it's just I feel
like a little bit too much at once I do
need to get my cardio Fitness up though
I know my cardio Fitness level is
definitely uh low which is not standing
treadmill I have an elliptical in the
room over how often do you use it well
now nothing but I did for a bit again I
fell off that wagon you know what you
might be a little too intimidating if I
came in and you're just like jacked and
you're telling me how to run my finances
here it's not it's got a thick
but imagine you come in like Ronnie
Coleman you sit down biceps the point
that was a very good point it might
people might be a little more closed off
that's a really good point that's true
no I mean I would just like to get rid
of the belly and you know just feel
better have more energy and stuff like
that
um I will say and I don't let it count
for people on my show of only clean up
their stuff recently because like okay
but you've demonstrated for like a year
that it's bad but these last few weeks
have been better my film guys in the
back there very fed goes to the gym
every day he's giving me a protein
blueberry smoothie recipe that I have
for lunch every single day and it goes
well unless a guest brings desserts
which is a better thing recently which
is harming me is it is it actually they
bring desserts yeah cookies or Donuts
cause they're awesome because they're
like the best people in the world how do
they know what to bring you I think
everyone likes donuts and cookies did
you make it public that you want people
to bring stuff this is the first time
that I think anyone would will have ever
heard that that's happened over and over
so people are recurring doing this not
right now but this has happened recently
a few times one person did bring Sprouts
okay that's good that's good did you eat
them yes I was munching on them a lot
they were actually quite tasty yeah
Sprouts are good um yeah they were uh
sunflower sprouts okay that was very
cool uh so I have a good clean day have
my blueberry smoothie yum yum yum yum
yum
so I had like a nibble I'll tell you my
weakness is seeing food go to waste so
if I see a whole tray of cookies and I
know they're going to be thrown out I
feel so bad about them being wasted that
I'll want to eat them not because I'm
hungry but I don't want them to be
thrown out ma'am so for me it's that
and so I will engage in desserts because
I just don't want to go to waste I will
say on the aspect of my health that I
think is rare for other people this is
not a brag but just curiosity because I
think you've talked about it I'm like oh
there's another weird person out
there I've never smoked a cigar in my
life I don't smoke anything and I do not
drink at all I've just never had the
interest in any of those things which I
know is beneficial health-wise extremely
extremely I mean alcohol is just toxic
basically yeah that's good that's great
yeah yeah for me it ruins my day the
next day and every now and then I'll
have a drink but it's just the next day
I just count it out that's a done day
yeah and I feel like crap and then the
next day I'm like is it really worth it
now there's been very few times where I
look back at that drink and like yeah
that drink was worth it if my friends
pester me enough I'll have a singular
sex on the beach because it tastes like
candy
I just don't like the taste of alcohol
it's not even an alcohol thing I just
hate the taste I don't like yeah I
really don't like beers I don't like
alcoholic beverages this is like ah
alcohol just straight alcohol is gross
yeah like a virgin drink it will taste
better than a you know alcohol yeah I
just want to pop that's my thing popper
water
give it to me so there's a lot of sugar
though so we could get those I go diet
yeah okay I'm a Diet Coke okay that's
good yeah
back onto the finances so we have these
people they come out of the show you've
noticed the pattern of people being
irresponsible with their car purchases
as well as going out are there any other
patterns because I want people that are
watching this maybe that are slipping to
be able to acknowledge and think like
hey how are my finances doing and be
cognizant about money yeah and maybe
consider these things that you've
recognized as patterns that let people
slip into not being well one thing that
has shown up a lot that is in less
people's control than the other
categories but I think people have a
little more control over than they're
willing to uh admit is cost of housing
so Austin's an expensive city for Texas
you know compared to LA or New York it's
certainly not but
like a guest was on the other day he was
spending like close to two thousand
dollars with barely any income on rent
and he was like if I'm gonna have to
move back home and I'm like dude you can
find places here they might not be the
grandest of places but you can find
places here like under a thousand
dollars to like a studio it's like that
doesn't exist so I pulled up Zilla real
quick showed him I think it was like 32
complexes with different units of under
a thousand dollars so that exists but
yes I mean for someone making even a
hundred thousand dollars a year in New
York City or la like housing is going to
be a larger percentage than we would
normally want them to see so that's a
big one that definitely hurts people
because it takes way a lot of their
money from their investing goals and
paying off goals so sometimes it's under
control sometimes it's not and I think
it's in more people's control than
they're willing to admit some of the
time but I think it's a really unpopular
opinion when you recommend people move
in order to save money because they
think hey look I am deserving of living
where I please because this is where I
it's my home something feels very like
like it's a part of your identity where
you live so I think they place a lot of
importance on it I think a lot is all
also the distance to where they work so
someone could justify and say well my
job is five minutes away and if I move
then my commute turns into 40 minutes
we've had a few of those you know like
my gas will more than make up for it
exactly which sometimes yeah I mean all
the prices are kind of high right now
sometimes it can make up for it but
what's the worst episode that you've
done where you look back and this
person's in the worst financial position
um because there's been a few where
you've said this is the worst finances
I've ever seen as a title yeah but what
is actually the worst it's someone that
I haven't had an update from and I'm
really sad about that uh she came she's
one of my first few episodes and you
know like I said now in this whole Year
everyone and even most of last year
honestly has been from the audience so
good relationships they're very happy to
do the show when I was first doing the
show and not a single episode was
released that we recorded four episodes
and I put out a call in Austin for
anyone to come on the show I'd give them
like 50 bucks which is like all I had at
the time to be on the show there was
someone with 250 000 in private student
loan debts a variable High interest
rates I can't imagine what those
interest rates are like now because
they're at 10 then they started at like
150 in only a few years wow they went to
250 000 they're going to be a million
dollars before she knows it and she
really doesn't use it's for social work
so gives these loans uh well that's
surprising to me that someone saw that
and checks the box say yeah we're gonna
give you the money I know right personal
responsibility is very important I will
say in this situation she certainly got
by her dad her dad she shouldn't
have done it but as an impressionable
teenager getting out of high school her
dad was like signed alone I'll pay for
it I'll pay for it her dad's a ghost
sitter essentially and has become this
has been a complete tear in the
relationship so they haven't you know
seen each other ghost because of the
loan I don't remember exactly
that's how many conversations that would
be gnarly if he just couldn't make the
payments and that's an awkward
conversation to have with your daughter
she wanted to go to an in-state School
in California that was public and save a
lot of money he was like go to Baylor
that's where I want you to go borrow as
much as it take I will pay Taylor Baylor
is a out of state private institution so
she she did get in it but because
of that and with a degree that doesn't
make as much money that has to be one of
the more daunting situations I've ever
seen and she you can see in her finances
that she's given up how would you
recommend for somebody like her what
would she do what did I recommend
um you can't you can't discharge student
loans and bankruptcy that's why they're
so terrible because they allow an 18
year old kid to take on hundreds of
thousands of dollars of debt regardless
of what they want to study and there's
no recourse you can't discharge that in
bankruptcy because you're getting an
education the education stays with you
so you just get screwed yeah there's no
way around it it's terrible and the fact
that people sign off on that when they
could buy a house with it I do you know
and at least they could claim the house
back but no that's why the student loans
there's no recourse on that I think
instead what would be interesting is if
they give the education to you for free
but they get a percentage of what you
make uh you know for life let's just say
so if you want the public school that's
30 000 well now you give one percent of
your income but if you want the private
school that costs x amount you give
maybe a little more like up to a certain
limit so it's not you know billions of
dollars necessarily but I don't think
you're like lighting the fire under
these students butts though for them to
like go out get a job because hey I
gotta pay this off so well that's a
thing too yeah I didn't think this
through because then you could just say
well now I'm not going to make any money
or make you know do stuff on the side
just don't report it in other
conversation that needs to happen as a
guy who has lots of music friends I
studied in school music I loved my
school music they excelled at quite a
few things like jazz and music therapy
and stuff like that you know I love the
experience
not every single college in the United
States needs to offer a music degree or
an arts degree these are industries that
the vast minor the small minority make
it right and that's okay
and I think anyone should pursue it with
that expectation of knowing it's going
to be hard and they can totally do that
but when a college of
10 000 people in the middle of Iowa or
whatever is offering these degrees that
have training that are lackluster
compared to other institutions and are
setting their students up for failure
they're responsible that institution to
even offer that degree in the first
place but I get it because the college
wants some money you got the professors
they're on payroll they're getting
tenure you got the the college you got
the all the executive administrators
yeah administrators that take up a
massive percentage of uh payroll for
colleges so I think it's irresponsible
for that every single institution in the
United States regardless of them and we
have a billion of them needs to offer
every degree even if that education for
that degree at that institution is not
going to be as good as it could be
somewhere else how do we get that girl
back in the podcast I don't think she
wants to again she wasn't from the
audience
um I cut out a lot of things that she
wanted me to cut out including even
after the fact uh can you get can you
gift her something towards the student
loans in exchange for coming on I think
I even gave her a big chunk of money
after the fact because I was like hey
you're one of the first people on the
the episode I know you weren't thrilled
with the experience which by the way we
sent out a survey to all the past guests
this year and we got an average four out
of five in terms of the experience the
only thing that people don't like is
that we rush a lot they feel but either
way she's one of the first guests yeah
and uh because she didn't even know what
the show was I didn't even know what the
show was I think she was just oh this
one in front of more people than I was
expecting than any of us expected so
yeah I don't think she wants to be in
front of that same amount of audience
again Fair rough situation though yeah I
feel so bad for her and I would
no I'd love to help in any way whatever
hopefully the budget I gave her I I know
in those situations some people I I will
also say are just for context because
I've read it a few places that
um I was nicer in those earlier episodes
uh in her situation stuff like that uh
in that I'm not me or anything like that
when I get like intense and stuff like
that no I'm actually I'm like actually
along with my personality to come
through now when I was first getting
started I had no idea what a YouTube
video took I was trying to level back
you know don't want to put off things
especially while I have another job I
don't want to come across as rude so I
was just a lot more things were just
tame and just chill including her
episode but now I'm literally just me I
just try to be the most open honest
person I can be at all times but well
now people know what to expect yeah
they know that you're probably gonna
yell at them yeah okay well it also
depends on the people's situation we had
a dude unfortunately experiencing
homelessness on recently I don't think
the voice was raised once in that
episode and I gifted him what he needed
to like uh his first two months of rent
I gifted him I gifted him a refrigerator
for his current situation so he could
didn't have to eat out all the time and
I gifted him
uh someone from the audience gifted him
a drone
um a drone because he was making good
money working for drone companies but
his drum broke down and then he went
homeless and then also I offered to pay
for his first four therapy sessions
because he has
um some really critical depression so I
love being in the position to be able to
help with that so it depends on the
episode but yes there are lots of people
like the model that you were talking
about who she wasn't receptive to
anything so naturally as me just being
me you know
I'm just very invested in it and I hate
when I care more about the situation
than they do but I also get equally as
excited when they pay off their debt
like dude I get so hype like you
have no idea when people are making
progress dude that emotion you see when
I'm angry is equal on the other side of
me being excited for them
because the Channel's only been around
for a year and a half and debt takes a
long time to pay off we've seen less of
that excitement we will though you got
to do like the Dave Ramsey debt free
scream yeah like your version of that
when they when they pay off like student
loans or something like that you know
when they do a six-month emergency fund
let's say have them come back and like
take a photo or something like that we
tell them to keep us updated all along
the way you know what you need Awards a
little trophies
and if you're on the show and they hit
certain Milestones let's just say paying
off their student loans six month
emerging you send them a little trophy
yeah of some sort I like that oh yeah I
think that would be a nice get like a
little bit bigger yeah they hit a
million dollar net worth they get you
know a big trophy yeah your face that's
sweet yeah yeah no that's actually
really cool no that's good that's good
well we get updates all the time from
people and people people are doing well
but again a lot of these death
situations if you watch the videos are
like multi-year payoffs so we won't see
the end session for a while so this guy
that was homeless for a little bit yeah
have you had any updates with him after
giving him the money in the refrigerator
the Drone hasn't updated us in a few
weeks so we leave it up to them to reach
out to us when they need help and when
they want but we tell them to don't like
you're not going to ignore it you're not
gonna Annoy Us reach out to us as much
as you can pester us for questions let
us help everything like that but we also
don't want to pester them and everything
right how are you doing how are you
doing are you about this week are you
better uh so I know he had a lot of
clinical stuff so I definitely don't
want to pester him but I very much want
to hear from him I haven't paid for the
therapy sessions yet because he hasn't
done them I'm offered to pay for them
but he needs to like you know sign up to
do it he can only do so much yeah I feel
and same same for the rent like I want
him to rent or put down a security
deposit whatever it was like I was going
to cover two months rent I think or a
security deposit plus one month rent he
has to go take the action to get the
place though and I'm fully willing and
excited to do it when he does it and
what are the character traits and
personality traits that you're seeing as
a pattern amongst people that are
financially irresponsible personality
traits I don't know I feel like we see a
wide range of that I think definitely
just a clear
people are very ignorant to personal
finances just as I was just as unsure we
all were at some point before we became
educated on things and you end up in the
situation
before you become enlightened but you
wanted to get better impulsive
personality trade or hmm it's actually a
good question I do try to get
carelessness I do try to get to the
bottom of the situation it's a little
hard I'm like why are you doing this and
a lot of people can give good answers
and I try to dissect that remember when
people are coming in though we're often
seeing a lot of the after effects of
past decisions so I can't see exactly
what they're doing in that moment what
we can definitely see for people who are
overspending instead of paying off debt
those kind of people you can see that
it's either lack of care uh or addictive
personalities kind of like even my own
with certain things and stuff like that
where they just like they feel like they
can't stop eating out and excuses are
being made so I think some of that when
it comes to people who are continuing
their bad bad behavior when they're on
the show so what's the path to getting
on track what do you recommend usually
for people step by step we lay out their
debt we figure out what the minimum
monthly payments are we add them up then
we get
uh what their budget is with the rent
some of the stuff they can't control
because they're already in it sure we
can maybe downgrade eventually but okay
that is what it is your debt is this I
put them on a grocery budget that's uh
can be healthily done but is also
limiting it just essentially involves
weekly meal prepping instead of like
cooking fresh pre-prepared meals every
day it's going to be more meal prepping
and then warming up and then basically
no fun except for a few unique
situations no paid for fun go have fun
uh sometimes increasing income by
getting a second job so we create once
we create what a potential income could
be plus a potential budget we then lay
out the best way to get out of the debt
sometimes that's a snowball method uh by
doing the uh smallest debt to the
largest debt sometimes it's the
Avalanche method by having the largest
interest rate to the smallest interest
rate really depends on their situation
and their mentality around it if you can
tell they're going to have a hard time
making through it snowball makes sense
from the emotional standpoint because
they start seeing they're making
progress you pay off that small debt
relatively easily but all of a sudden
you have a win so you start paying off
more Avalanche I like for people you can
tell are a little more fired up
discipline because mathematically
Avalanche method you pay less over time
so we figure out the best method to do
that but first we usually get them to
save up a one month emergency fund
whatever their budget was we get one
month sometimes if they have kids
multiple kids two months because if
anything happens we've also had people
on the show who have followed the baby I
love Dave Ramsey we're going to
collaborate with them I've been invited
on the show like twice yeah travel
anxiety uh but uh the thousand dollar
thing and I get his logic he's defended
it a lot especially recently even though
it hasn't been updated and he's
explained why we've had people on the
show especially early on the show who
did the Thousand hours to get out of
debt they started making progress on the
debt then an emergency happened and
there's basically no emergency that's
less than a thousand dollars then they
ended up in a worse situation than they
were before they even saved the thousand
dollars so I'm like okay let's make sure
if anything happens you can survive for
a month will you scour for income
sources or if you have a kid just to
make up for extra risk because you're
taking care of little ones okay let's
have two months of emergency funds then
we just beat that debt down and then
from there it depends on their age so 50
30 20 is a good standard just for people
to start a budget on fifty percent I
need 30 on Watts 20 on investing but if
someone's just getting out of debt
getting a fully funded emergency fund uh
you got to get a fully funded emergency
fund obviously first uh once you get out
of debt
if someone's starting at 50 and they
have zero dollars they basically gotta
start investing fifty percent of their
income if they're gonna try to retire
mid-60s you know maybe even 70. so it
depends on the age but so whatever their
budget allocation is going to be at
after that point depends where they are
in retirement because what I really try
to stress on the show I just want people
to be able to retire whether that's
their spending their pile of money to
Zero by the time they die or they're
leaving something left over for someone
else you know passing on money that's up
to them in the Avenue that they want to
save in order to get there how much they
want to save in order to get that pile
um what I just really try to stress is
that when parents are choosing
specifically parents are choosing fund
spending over paying off debt and
investing they are putting that on their
kids to be morally responsible to take
care of their parent when they retire
and have no money that seems like a
cultural thing though I do see some
cultures where that's the norm that's
expected that the kids are going to take
care care of their Elders in retirement
which is okay personally have no issue
with taking care of my parents but I
think it being in the choice of the kids
would be better than it being put upon
the kids I agree so if you have chosen
to blow all your money go into a bunch
of debt you make it to 70 something
happens you can't work who knows the
Social Security is going to be like at
that point then okay I have no money to
survive uh I don't think Mike I don't
think I'm gonna let Mom and Dad die on
the street yeah so right that's up to
the parents and the kids but it's
important to make sure that the parents
are aware that they are putting that
pressure on the kids yeah because a lot
of them could just be living financially
irresponsibly yeah and not really
understanding that hey eventually Down
the Line This is this will be on your
kids oh again there's lots of ignorance
and ignorance is okay
that you just don't know you don't know
what you don't know so that's why you
know we try to do you tell them do you
ever have people question whether or not
you're qualified to give them advice
I've had interviews where people ask
that or people get upset
um but then I'm very clear that we don't
talk about different investment vehicles
that's usually what you're licensed to
talk about right
if you need a specific license to say
hey if you make 100 a month you
shouldn't spend 120 on fast food you
know honestly off like I mean
that's pretty basic stuff and I think
that's very important for people to hear
about and okay even if people are upset
that sure there's no CPA and I'm telling
someone they shouldn't spend more money
than they make I don't care that little
hate that a couple people might give
because we get thousands and thousands
and thousands of people reaching out
saying yo in the comment section email
social media wherever yo I paid off my
debt because of this Channel and that is
everything dude I don't even care right
now I know right now I could uh back out
of all my uh stocks my personal
residence and get everything into the
cash flowing type properties that I have
up in Michigan and I could generate ten
thousand dollars ish a month I could do
that and do this show for free because
the biggest reward is the progress that
people make it's just it's so hype it's
so hype when people turn their lives
around it's just crazy why not go for
like the certified financial advisor
license uh I mean at this point I just
don't feel like it's worth my time sure
I mean cool it would be cool to talk
people through investing and stuff like
that and I have my own opinions on
investing I do my own investing yeah uh
but I don't feel like it's worth my time
and also I think where the average
American is it's more beneficial to help
the people that are in the Dire Straits
and sit down with someone and be like
okay sure you have 43 of your Investment
Portfolio in the S P 500 but maybe let's
do 45 yeah or something like that I
think it's going to be more beneficial
to help someone learn how to budget and
uh stop around I agree I think
that's like the foundation of being good
with finances is like budgeting and what
I tell all my friends that come to me
because they know like I am somewhat in
like the YouTube Finance industry like
some somewhat related they would say hey
Jack how do I get good with money like
what do you recommend investing and I
always just say like you just have to be
aware conscious and intentional of money
in general if you want to learn how to
be good with money you have to just be
conscious of money what is money what
does money do for you what do you do for
money where is your money going be aware
of your relationship with money and that
is like the strongest Foundation that
you can have to be to being uh
financially free or secure yeah
and another thing honestly again because
I don't do this for clout I hate like as
I said at the beginning I honestly hate
my social media presence I don't like
being known it's weird I don't like it
if people are like oh okay you know I've
heard enough bad stories of people like
I want to learn how to invest for money
guys money guys are great I love them
I'm friends with them they're coming
down here watch them support them
they're good I'm totally okay take a few
weeks off my videos learn some stuff
from them totally good I'm not doing
this for cloud I'm doing it to help
people so that's totally chill so I
don't think I need to talk about
investing because people like them exist
and they are so good at what they do and
they're very educational what's the back
end of your business in terms of how
many people you have working with you
two full-time employees one person that
helps with thumbnails that cost a
thousand dollars a month two thousand
dollars a month then I pay someone very
part-time a thousand dollars a month to
do
some spreadsheet work
um and then I pay both of my employees
if I'm doing better they're doing better
because a lot of it is the commission
based and just Revenue they're both
making six figures and I want them to be
making a ton of money eventually so
which is great because I love rewarding
dude they're making my lives so much
easier they're helping me make money I
want them to make money so
yeah uh they're both making six figures
I want to give out like a big yearly
bonus
don't be too excited they're in the room
right now I do want to if this is your
hundred dollars Chris 100 bill because I
yeah again as we talked about at the
beginning
the money that I'm all of a sudden
starting making I don't get it it
doesn't make sense it's a number that's
not real
I don't need it also I want to make sure
they're making money too
a videographer role in an editing role I
could get away with an awesome paying
fifty thousand dollars a year this dude
makes well over six figures produce a
role I could probably do something same
how many inquiries do you get every day
at people who want to be on the show
producer
30 or 40 a day and what do you look for
in this 30 or 40 that make you want to
pick them to be on camera she compiles
them into especially and we we make sure
that there are diverse enough situations
and situations that we can help the most
because again a lot of them they're not
like it'd be fun to be on camera some
people want to do it for Club but some
people are like dude I'm literally gonna
be homeless next month please help me
give me anything and they want to get
they want to get sat down they want some
tough love and they want a budget made
out in a plan so usually the people we
can help the most is who we go for are
you worried about it eventually becoming
too repetitive sure but again
it's
we talked about the dream 15 million
dream 15 million doesn't need to happen
as long as it's actually helping people
and I'm able to pay the bills and I
don't ever have to let someone go like
I'm totally okay as long as it's helping
people because that's the main goal in
the end there is the extra stressor of
having the payroll now you know again
paying for the rent paying for the food
doing all this stuff and I love that and
I love the team relationship that we
have here but if it gets repetitive
there's other shows I want to do for fun
but as long as I'm helping people on the
show that's the ultimate reward which
sounds so corny and so many people
aren't going to believe that because who
the says that but I actually
believe it one thing that I've noticed
just being friends with you because I
mean we haven't really established this
quite yet but you and I we talk I feel
like no pretty regularly like I'll give
you a call you'll give me a call we
check in with each other you'll send me
a photo of you like hey man do you
prefer the beard or do you prefer
without the beard which I prefer with
the beard no you are extremely genuine
and sincere the thing that I've noticed
is you you're very blunt you're very
honest your personality on camera is
exactly how you are off camera and I
mean so many people on a regular basis
that appear on camera and they're
entertainers that are not entirely how
they are in real life but you I can say
with full confidence you're extremely
genuine extremely sincere and I really
appreciate that about you I really
appreciate it Shameless like honestly
like yeah yeah like you're like talking
about dating talking about this talking
about that like you know what I mean
what's the point life is too short why
not just be open I agree with you it's
just I respect the uh that ability to I
don't know I would say kind of be
careless towards other judgments you
know what I mean yeah yeah I try again
it's when people assume I'm like
something different or having negative
intentions around the show that gets to
me I think they're kind of evil people
but and the thing is when you say that
you genuinely care about the financial
well-being of the people that come on
the show I without a doubt believe it
100 wholeheartedly because I know for a
fact just based off of the way that you
treat money the way you talk about the
income that you have how I know your
income has increased over time and how
that's affected you which is not at all
really
um that it really is about the guests
that come on your show and you really do
just like want to help them and we could
so easily record an episode and say okay
goodbye we really try to be as much as
they want it's up to them be a part of
their lives what do you think your
financial weaknesses are fast food
again nothing we we went over it and it
was like it's not a financial weakness
because that that there's implications
on your finances are negative that's
more of a health okay that's more of a
healthy because there's point seven
percent of mine right Financial weakness
oh we talked about some indecisive
things I did uh upgrade my living
situation because I wanted a yard for
the pups I wanted
um more space to do more shows and do
more things I was feeling very tight in
my condo even though I like the location
I also wanted to be much closer to my
friends who you know we all hang out
like almost every day
very lucky because not a lot of people
are that lucky in their 20s or 30s or
40s or their life but whatever so that
maybe the impulsive decision to
upgrade quite a bit and for Austin for
what the house is in Austin it's
actually quite affordable but the
interest rates are around the thing is I
mean you still could have bought a house
way bigger way nicer way more expensive
Etc than this so technically speaking
you still kind of bought underneath what
I would say the financially
irresponsible or even the average person
would have done in your financial
situation yeah I went to The Burbs 914
000 20 down six point whatever percent
interest rate but in this exact house
and next to my condo in the neighborhood
behind it would have gone for easily
minimum five million dollars so I feel
okay what's tough for me as a real
estate guy to look at the rents right
now in the areas yeah you could rent
almost a brand new construction that
they couldn't sell Seven Grand a month
no money down and you have the freedom
to pick up a move wherever you want to
yeah and you have that extra 20 which is
almost two hundred thousand dollars to
go and invest elsewhere at a higher
return you put that in the Michigan
properties that you're buying no you're
right so one of my personal flaws lack
of patience so I couldn't find anything
for that
couldn't find anything for that within a
week couldn't find anything for that
within two weeks okay that's done search
is done I I'm gonna go get this house
that I really liked I'm gonna visit
if I'm gonna do this thing it needs to
be really good like everything here is
done top level so I was really excited
about it like there were lots of nice
new constructions but everything here is
top level one of my friends is
thrillingly excited about the level five
drywall whatever the that is every
time he comes in oh gosh I know no he's
excited about it I'm not I don't care
level five drywall is like it's a finish
on the drywall that makes it incredibly
smooth I don't this is painted over we
repainted so I don't you're not gonna
feel it here but you're gonna feel it on
the other one it's drywall that they
finish they'll sand it they'll polish it
they'll sand it they'll polish it and
they do that like five times it's a
level five fish you don't it's like it's
a high-end thing
yeah but it's like what I pay more yeah
I don't care no oh gosh now mine you see
the Spackle job on the side you don't
have level five drywall no it's a waste
of money I didn't pay for it completely
it's a complete waste of money the
premium the Builder will charge on it's
not like the Builder's doing this out of
the goodness of their heart they know
level five drywall I was like how much
those are lost money on this with the uh
cost to build it and the cost to buy the
property they lost money on it well I
think but a lot of sellers are going to
be losing money yeah that's what I think
building right now I feel really bad is
it was there it was their first building
and design so it was kind of that's the
risk that's the risk they take no you're
right I don't really feel that way you
know
it's the risk they take but it's you
know I did a whole video recently that's
posting uh first week of October about
buying versus renting and I went through
in today's market and I analyzed the
average price based on the average
income of a person versus the average
rent and I based off a 400 000 home uh
the monthly payments all in on that and
I calculated the opportunity cost what
the home is going to be worth after like
10 years everything rents are still
substantially cheaper over the lifetime
of the average ownership of 13 years
interesting if you plan to live in the
home for less than about 11 and a half
years if you're in here for 13 14 years
and you sell and now I am also assuming
that you're selling and you're paying a
six percent commission on closing costs
so that's factored in there my realtors
very nice one usually gives me the three
percent love you okay well then you'll
save the three percent so maybe for you
it's nine years if if you're going to be
in this house for the next 10 years
fantastic decision probably based on
these projections if you're only going
to be in here a few years and then you
know I might sell it uh and then move
somewhere else chances are
it would have been way cheaper to rent
you're totally it's the mobility and
right now what I feel like is you're in
this upward trajectory and 10 years a
night I think your life is gonna look
totally different it's gonna it's gonna
be wildly different than it is today
and so I think even five years from now
could be wildly different it's
projecting whether or not you're still
going to be here at that point yeah I
regret the decision overall financially
with the house and where it is and be
closer friends I don't regret it
likewise but I definitely I do regret it
financially and it's
maybe the first not complete okay it
wasn't incredibly stupid mistake like I
still have equity in the home whatever
it's an overall investment so it's not
like I just did something aggressively
stupid but in terms of my financial
decisions within the last five seven
years wasn't definitely probably so far
lower subpar I always text Jack and I'm
like Jack please help me stop being
single he's like dude just a shut up you
big fat nerd come on every time every
time he just bullies me he just hit the
gym get a six-pack why do you not want
to be single what's the problem man oh I
think I'd joke about it more than
essentially reality like I joke about so
many things that so many people take so
literally which is okay this is my
personality but no I mean in general
it's like okay so what am I doing here
okay maybe I'm making a good amount of
money now what's the point of it all if
I'm not passing it on to someone if I'm
not sharing the life with someone it's
just like what's your point of young
though you're in your 20s almost not
yeah
so what's but what's the rush oh I guess
there's no rush but also I like the
experience of dating I like the
connection yeah I do enjoy looking for
right now in a relationship uh
oh all right Shameless let's go let's do
it uh definitely a long-term partner but
I have found myself doing more temporary
uh things for some reason are you in
those relationships is that what you go
into it looking for is something I think
it's a bit more short-term or like why
do you end up are you initially looking
for long term and you end up settling
for short term because that's just the
default it's kind of the easier path to
go on maybe it's because it's the easier
path and there's also just like innate
desires that I think just get away then
I'm just stupid or here's the thing is
it is it is it you choosing the short
term or is it them choosing the short
term
mean and maybe sometimes them as well I
mean I'm not gonna put the blame on
anyone else the thing is the unfortunate
reality at least uh what I think is the
case is that you have not found the
perfect person yet and once you do
you're not going to want a short-term
relationship with them you win I don't
want a short-term relationship I just
think you're opting for it I just think
yeah it just tends to happen uh it's
just I think maybe I have a lot of
expectations and I was just I honestly
don't know I can't pinpoint this I can't
pinpoint this I'm in the exact same
situation interesting the exact same
situation I want a long-term
relationship I cannot pinpoint why I
don't want to go on second dates with
the people I go on first dates with oh I
don't know why and I think it's an
expectation standard thing but I really
do not know Jack seems to get
discouraged easily though like there's
little like you know small things and
I'm like yeah he's not that big of a
video
but not even putting up with it
sometimes it's just like Jack just won't
text back for like a month and then just
like there's a random that's usually due
to a lack of interest on my end if I
don't text back for a month you better
not be ghosting don't ghosts that's so
mean to people don't ghost Jack you
can't ghost you gotta be nice to people
don't don't
ghosts me so many texts I send Jack
attacks out on your back
you're drawing assumptions here I he
just says something right he made it
sound like a ghost jump on it okay
but he'll text back Weeks Later can I
please just like mid conversation why is
he speaking on my channel
let me answer on Behavior just talk to
me speak to my representative I'd rather
hear any and every day sorry you're
another ugly I don't want
to see you again they just never get a
text I would rather hear that every
single day is it my turn oh
yeah okay
to explain myself I do not ghost per se
they do not text me two three times in a
row and I don't get back to them I will
always get back a lot of the times what
ends up happening unfortunately yes this
is my bad I should be better about this
is also hey I'll text you a week from
now and I don't text them a week from
now that's what happens but they also if
they are texting me expecting a response
I will always get back to him 100
without a doubt sometimes not if it's
Graham I will say the timeline he didn't
mention in Timeline he says I'll get
back yes but it's not it's not a week
like it's not it's not even more than
you know two days like it's like there
was one that went like a month that was
and he was and he was like Graham why is
she not taking them
four years ago I try to make that very
good yeah
like bully in high school man we don't
we don't judge wait maybe not high
school why were you a bully like Middle
School maybe I don't know because I was
a dick uh just because maybe
insecurities and just whatever figures
so what would you do I don't know I
think just like make fun of take kids
lunch money no that was not for physical
so it's more like a joke on someone
else's expense you know were they were
they PR like were they laughing about
the joke or was it more like ah you know
maybe it was more Elementary School I
found better friends you know late
Middle School uh high school and then
growth and then I think I was always
just like trying to be the class clown
in high school and stuff like that so I
was still like a dumbass at the teachers
probably hated and stuff like that but
we don't judge you for what you did two
years ago because we all go through
personal growth we learn we can look
back and learn but we only judge you for
what you do now in your ghost and Graham
very mean I don't go scram I'm gonna
swipe through some of our texts right
now and I'll show you guys I actually
get back very quickly I'll let you know
he never goes man okay he never goes man
some people he text back fast me I don't
think I'm on that priority list okay
well anyways to bring this conversation
back to Earth Caleb yeah you're looking
for the girl of your dreams oh yes okay
now what does this girl look like what
does she do I don't know I don't
my friends say I have a high standard I
probably do I don't know
I can't describe a physical type I feel
like I'm in a wide variety of
communities okay yeah it's just like if
that person's the person boom boom boom
physical is obviously very important to
get into the get to know your face at
least for me uh and then I like someone
who's definitely ambitious doesn't want
to just you know just lay around all day
but then someone who's also maybe a
little more introverted like I am I'm
not a I like to hang out with my friends
a lot but I don't like to just go douche
and I'm not hit it hit the clubs hit the
bar kind of guy so someone wants to drag
me to that stuff that's not gonna work
uh like some sport restaurants I don't
know sounds like a dating profile
doesn't it and I'm reading off
um classic stuff like that I think
ambition's a very that sounds about
right and I agree I think it's hard to
like pinpoint a specific like visual
profile of someone you're interested in
however it's just like sounds super
super lame super annoying but it's like
an energy like you show up to somebody
you talk to him and you're just like you
know what I really like the way this
person carries themselves I really like
how they talk how excited they seem
about this or that the passion that I
see in this like that's just attractive
and you can't pinpoint what it is you
find in them that is attractive but they
are just attractive to you you know and
that happens but I'm very very very rare
occasions and that's kind of what I'm
holding out for no no
sure I mean I like to go on dates so I
go on dates when's the last date you
went on it was last week I don't
remember what day it was fine fine oh
yeah it was okay I think we just agreed
that I just think we agreed that Friends
with Benefits would probably be better
for our living situation okay so was
there physical attraction yeah sure sure
well yeah yeah I'm being vague because
I'm uncomfortable do you know I want to
talk about this no no let's talk about
it I'll talk about it okay so you where
did you go on the state we just went to
a place called The Domain here
okay now this is so we walked around we
got some boba what are you liking her uh
well again this is a friends with
benefits so we really don't really get
to know each other very much so how do
you agree to those terms open and honest
you're just like hey is that like the
initial message no okay so it was
actually it kind of came up this was
only discussed in person yeah I don't
remember because I don't even think I
was the one who first brought it um I
think we were talking about what we're
each looking for yeah and I think that's
what was it just like a difference
they're leaving after a year so uh so
you're like you know what I think the
best I think they said they're only
[Music]
if you're looking for something
long-term and serious why spend your
time on that when you could not spending
time on it really is this existing yeah
but you're putting energy into this they
could be spent you know growing the
business spent looking elsewhere hitting
the gym honestly I'm not spending much
energy on it I'll be honest this is I've
seen her twice but it could be mental
energy last week yeah since last week
yeah and how many times you go to the
gym
zero
okay all right okay I think long term I
yes I would like to find a partner
I was talking to a few
a person who was long distance but it
just didn't really why do you want to
find a partner I don't know it just it
seems to be what I'm missing I just I've
I don't know I've always kind of craved
it and then I've always failed at dating
but you know but so it's something
you're missing but you feel like
how do you know it's that how do you
know I guess I don't so you're trying to
not necessarily but I feel like that's
missing what are you missing from that
specifically that the human connection
the partnership you know kind of
building life together on just a future
and stuff but I feel like you have that
with your friends and people that work
with you I do but I mean you're building
a future with everyone in this room
you've seen the charts of like
uh the people you spend time with spend
time with and it's like it just but and
then everyone's like significant other
because your friends because it's just
the older you get the less you want to
deal with that's it so the less
people you see you're more selective
okay all sort of my friends can't do as
much and I'm very blessed to have a
great friend group yeah then I'm just
here I'm just sitting here I'm bored
alone I'm not very extra important but
boredom isn't good though I I think you
should fill the boredom with with other
hobbies and things that you're
interested like yeah I love the aquarium
too but it uh my wallet hates it see I
think you'll find the best relationship
as soon as you're content just being
single living your life
like that that's the way it was for me I
was so happy just doing my thing not not
a care in the world no one to answer
nothing and then I ended up getting a
relationship right afterwards but I
wasn't looking for a single thing guys
I'm not looking for anything right now
but I think when you get to that point
where you're so comfortable and like
self-assured in who you are that nothing
phases you anymore that's the point
where you become really attractive to
other people it's just hey I'm perfectly
single uh happy with the way things are
going I don't need a single thing in the
world well again I'm very I'm very very
honest I
[Music]
except for the one thing I told you guys
so just someone think like if people
think I'm like an evil person or
something like that that's the only
thing because this is not me and this is
weird if other people think that but
either way other than that really
nothing else gets to me so I don't part
of me wonders though people could sense
that you're looking to fill something so
that when you're when you're dating I
will say you're like I move too quick I
move too quick I could tell by we looked
through a few of your messages on your
video and you can look through it
move too quickly in the sense of like go
right for the date yeah immediately like
you're here
is because you have to build some sort
of connection and Rapport before meeting
next with her in person okay all of
those texts are not building Rapport in
the beginning it's just exchanging
pleasantries and yeah but when a girl
has a hundred messages and all of them
are let's go on a date let's go on a
date how should it differentiate I think
that is atypical to escort a day right
out the gate well also if you if you
look through a woman's profile like that
she's gonna have so many messages how do
you differentiate yourself from 50 other
guys talking to her on the same day
trying to have the same conversations as
you are you're the one asking for a date
why should she pick you over everyone
else I'll tell you
my British impression I didn't find it
funny I liked it he found it funny yeah
Jack's not the best uh engage on that
I'm gonna say it okay it's true 33. hold
you 24. I think I would be the game
by one year I'm in between
that women mature slightly faster than
men so the fact that if if you know
someone's Jack stage they're going to be
more mature you know I'm just saying so
maybe they're closer to my age mentally
okay well I mean you know I just don't
like the I just don't like the
I just want to meet and get to
know someone I hate the as you
call exchanging pleasantries I call it
I just want to meet and get to
know someone I don't get to know someone
you know
yeah I don't like sex so to me it's it's
like someone asking for a job interview
be like I'm not going to send you my
resume just give me the interview
interesting you know and you're like who
are you no just give me the interview
trust me I'm gonna knock it out of the
park just give me the interview oh you
want to hear my Morgan Freeman
impression check this out British Morgan
Freeman are British oh Morgan Freeman in
it
wait I'm Logan Freeman I can't do it I
feel like that's better you feel like
that's a better idea all right all right
okay
dial it back in yeah okay so you got an
interest in finance from actually coming
up or being brought up in a pretty
how do you say like not impoverished but
like not not well off not well to do
home at all definitely born very low
middle class oops baby you know
teenagers type of thing late teens uh
dad just working at a grocery store mom
just being like a clerk at like a
eyeglass place so like no money's coming
in uh so I mean I think that's just
another reason why I want to make sure I
get to a point where there's good cash
flow coming in because you can't rely on
this thing especially a job that I don't
like lots of aspects of it
um and then just like as we went
throughout the years just Finance
struggles that they hid from me very
well they're still making sure that I
had I felt like I was living in a middle
class life like I was able to take trips
I got instruments stuff like that but it
was all financed like taking out second
mortgages type things stuff like that
all to make it feel like the kids were
giving getting that good life and then
even as we were getting closer to
college like foreclosure notices on the
household and stuff like that so really
just seeing that seeing parents struggle
it's not only the reason why I wanted to
better my finances but it's definitely
one of the reasons I want to do this
show because so many people are in that
position you know how are your parents
finances today much better youngest
brother in other groups baby love you
Braxton he is actually growing up that
middle class household that they
pretended we were growing up so my dad
ended up starting a business uh and it's
taken off he's a third owner in it of a
fire water restoration type business and
fire and floods always happen uh and
that he's you know serving the community
he's been doing really well my mom went
back I got a Nursing degree she's been
very successful in her field and they're
doing you know they've paid off so much
bad debt and I've you know given them
advice on what I think should be paid
off as well I think they only have like
their mortgage left if you're not
mistaken like a low interest like maybe
stay together all this time yeah yeah
that's really impressive and they're
taking a well-deserved trip to Australia
which I'm so happy this is the first
international trip I think I think maybe
in Mexico uh so that's really cool but
definitely my situation growing up
hidden you could start catching wind of
it and then in hindsight you can
definitely tell was definitely lower
middle class for a long time
um but they're doing really well now on
them how do you think that affected your
relationship with money or your interest
towards Finance scarcity mindset
scarcity do you think that you picked up
on that from your parents no not
necessarily because again they hid it
quite well it was just more towards
starting to understand what money even
is in your teens and then in hindsight
kind of understanding how things were
that I understood it but
just not wanting to be in that situation
not wanting to have a foreclosure notice
type warning on this house ever you know
not wanting to if I ever have kids I
wanted them to be able to do whatever
they want to do you know that's healthy
and good send them to college like
college wasn't even couldn't even come
close to be paid for for me took out a
bunch of student loans and they took out
Parent Plus student loans so it's like
yeah one of my dreams dreams is to I
want to hit that 50 that five million
dollar Mark but I also want to pay off
the remaining mortgage
that's a big dream of mine as well did
you ever get evicted or you're talking
about a forklift very close Okay
warnings very behind on payments second
mortgages well maybe a third mortgage I
don't even know this is you know always
take advantage of whatever little Equity
there is in that uh house and just
taking out credit cards and this is
credit cards was everything credit cards
credit cards credit cards and seeing how
that's impacted people big inspiration
for why
I want to help people as well that are
in the same situations were they smart
with their finances though taking out
those mortgage I mean they never
effectively actually lost oh no housing
right and I've I've talked to them about
that recently they knew nothing
they could have been better off oh they
probably could have been leveraged
different resources take out debt in
different ways in a smart way if you
know exactly what the implications of
your actions will be yeah incomes were
certainly definitely limited for quite a
while but we could have strictly
budgeted and done well just like many
people on the show uh but uh yeah
absolutely but then if you budgeted like
that it would have been more apparent to
the children that oh you're struggling
financially absolutely and especially
because eventually after I was five we
moved from a more sketchy place to a
wealthy School District though we
weren't wealthy you know we were in that
District if we were budgeting heart they
wanted me to live the lives of the
neighbors you know the people that I
went to school with who were able to
take trips who were able to participate
in different activities and stuff do you
think that that helped develop your
character in the way that they maybe
would have wanted like did it actually
improve
maybe subconsciously I think that's one
point why I got interested in real
estate in general is because I saw that
as a cash flow opportunity something
that you can always have on the
background when did you go to that
school district the nicer one of the
kindergarten so I didn't have very much
time in the in the really sketchy area
to be honest is that when you became a
bully
[Music]
I think that's just more broad than it
was I mean I was with the wrong crew in
elementary school just bad influences
people who
I feel bad for saying this I got into a
good friend group they've continued
falling back on their social media
they're not really doing anything right
now they're not living a very good life
but being mixed up with them for a while
until I had a big falling out in middle
school so you know they do bad things to
people not bad things to people again
that makes it sound like we're stabbing
people in the parking lot or something
it's like just like making fun of
someone or something you know or we're
playing soccer and then you're like and
like someone Falls over on the
playground like oh my goodness that kind
of stuff yeah uh but just wasn't a good
person and that is not the type of
person you want to continue and grow up
and be yeah not that I'm close but what
made you make that change when did you
recognize that maybe that's not who you
want to be well I'm definitely very
influenced by people I'm around and I
ended up getting into a better friend
group and they were good people
um and you know associating with good
people and you just kind of become a
better person I was still a Class Clown
just a bit wild but it didn't take it
out on other people specifically you
know bring others down to feel good or
anything like that so yeah but I mean
life is all about growth right so I'm of
course I would take back that I was a
bully but I don't sit here and just like
freak out about the fact that oh my gosh
I can't believe it was a boy it happened
learn from it hopefully use that
experience if I ever have kids to help
direct them through that situation my
parents didn't know by the way I was so
good at hiding things so good hiding
things it's masterful
um uh so it's a learning experience
20 years ago wasn't even close to
perfect I was better 15 years ago and I
was better than that 10 years ago and I
was better than that five years ago and
I'm better than I was five years ago now
so just always striving to get better is
very important what would you change
about yourself today well I did I can
definitely get in trouble with my uh
lack of filter and just complete honesty
because people take things wrong uh
people can take advantage of it and
uh
but also I just want to be me maybe some
of the more impossible things we talked
about that
um yeah I think that would be a big one
anxiety oh if so like literally change
anything yeah I'll just get rid of my
panic disorder but that's gone that
doesn't exist I could be living so much
what's it like to have a panic disorder
uh terrifying and very limiting
you're afraid of panic attacks in a
strict phobia way where it's like you
build your life around not having them
so wherever you found your safe place to
be this is like your life around that
and extra things can and that's another
reason why this job just isn't the job
for me is because it's so
anxiety-inducing
um and it triggers those panic attacks
and then you literally feel like you're
dying you can tell yourself you're not
dying doesn't matter your brain thinks
you're dying and then you
dramatically fear that like you fear
getting your hand cut off or something
like that you would avoid any situation
in the world to not have your hand cut
off it's like the same fear of that I'm
avoiding anything and everything that
could lead to a panic attack that I
could not get out of because it is the
most miserable thing in the world what
does it feel like you've never had a
panic attack
no no lucky you
um some people Associated like a heart
attack some people your brain just
thinks you're dying for me my heart
starts racing I get uh very clammy very
sweaty I breathe very fast I feel like
I'm going to pass out uh my brain is
convinced it's dying and I uh feel
incredibly depressed in the way where
every once in a while everyone so I
don't want people to freak out about
this but every once while in those
extreme situations Suicidal Thoughts can
happen but that's just because I feel
like it's something that's never going
to end because it feels like it's just
never ending and you think that's like
the easy way out and that's not
something I've considered or want to do
but that's just like in the most extreme
scary situation is something that
unfortunately veers its way how long do
they last it's hard you can get over it
pretty quickly I found good coping
mechanisms to get over it but I mean
I've had ones that have lasted like a
few hours and those are miserable but on
average average they feel I don't know I
don't time them they feel like they'll
last eternity but maybe
15 minutes I don't know it could be
longer and what's the frequency of them
it depends stress level and different
things going on right now I think with
this job higher
than before what are your coping
mechanisms distract myself play some
music watch something
try to take a nap or go to sleep why do
you think you have this no idea no idea
even if they start coming uh I remember
my first one taking a vacation in South
Carolina Early teenager it just happened
nothing triggered it happened thought I
was dying didn't know what a panic
attack was and then unfortunately
learning what a panic attack was I
developed a phobia for panic attack and
have you ever spoken to a
professionalism oh yeah no I'm on Celexa
but I think that's more for general
anxiety because my thing's more of a
phobia I don't know if you can medicate
a phobia I think it's more mental health
thing I was in therapy for a while I was
advocate for therapy I need to go back
in therapy I when I moved to my last
location I was far away from my
therapist I was like cancel and I just
need to get back on yeah it seemed like
it was such a traumatic event when it
happened the first time that you now
fear that happening again of reliving
that first time in that YouTube job that
I got turned down for after the fourth
day of supposed to meeting the person he
didn't show up the first three days the
fourth day I had one of those three hour
panic attacks I've had like twice in my
life maybe three times and I just
couldn't go I was like I'm sick and he's
like okay this isn't gonna work then so
it can definitely impact life in ways
that suck yeah in hindsight though
would you be here today if not for
calling in sick that time no
no no no no I mean that's great but
in the moment wasn't great and then my
anxiety was very bad for a few weeks I
was supposed to have friends come down
for bachelor party and stay with me a
few weeks later but my anxiety levels
were so high at that point where I just
needed space of my own it's actually one
reason I didn't let you guys stay with
me it's because I didn't want to have to
worry about potentially being getting
too anxious and having a moment and just
needing to be by myself so I put you
guys up in a hotel get that well if you
had a larger home
if you waited to buy something okay you
know I'm just saying you could rent it
you could you could rent a house it's a
little bit bigger I could just take a
loss on this house and just go get a
Mega Mansion let's do that
build something from scratch
so it's not fun it sucks and there's a
lot of people that deal with it I wish
there was a better way for us to treat
it but no one knows is what no one knows
what causes it or else we'd be treating
it right so therapy coping mechanisms
learning how to get over that so I
haven't come to Vegas I mean you
extended that invitation forever ago now
at least in the lifespan of my YouTube
channel and I really want to go there
those places I want to experience I've
never been to California
uh never been to the West Coast I've
never been west of here yeah
there's a lot of things I want to do and
that's going to require getting but
you're going to be going to see Dave
Ramsey soon so that's going to require
you I've been employed to see you Dave
Ramsey don't be on the show I haven't
not done it I haven't said no I'm just
trying to I just don't know what to do
it's so hard my plan is to right now the
plan is to rent an RV hire a driver and
then us as me and my team just play
games in the back how long is the drive
going to be 12 hours
I was on the drive to Michigan where my
family is quite a few times how long of
a flight is it like two hours three
hours two hours something like that
there's no way you could drive 12 fly to
I feel like the race when I'm on the
ground I'd be like turn this
around we're going home but I feel like
the ratios are off I feel like it's got
to be a longer than a 12 hour drive
in an RV you're driving 65 the entire
way okay maybe it's a little longer
because the RV it's gonna be like 13 14
without stopping yeah but I'm playing
Catan in the back for 14 hours sure
time's awesome
ish for that long I have a phobia
I have a phobia falling asleep in the
car
because I think if I fall asleep in a
car the car is going to flip over well
you drive
no he has a driver
yeah I know but like you mean if someone
else is driving oh yeah no no I'm not
like me driving falling asleep in the
car I'm saying if someone else is
driving that's what I meant driving it's
like no I'm saying if someone else is
driving the car I'm in the back seat I
I'm paranoid about falling asleep
because I can't see like what's going on
around me and prepare like if I see a
car flip in and I'm like you know I
could tense up a little bit so you
really see it coming that's a phobia
yeah I don't that's being but that's
just me falling asleep it's completely
irrational makes no sense and it's silly
and that's what I have with the other
thing so
I wish I had a reason or an excuse or uh
treatment
a lot of people I mean what they do is
they just do it I just gotta do it I
think you just gotta do it but doing it
is the hard part do you think you you'd
feel better afterwards getting through
that oh that if you could get through
that million percent a billion percent
so I think I would still be anxious
getting into the situation but you do it
once of course it gets the ball rolling
last time I was on a plane and the only
time I was on a plane was decade and a
half ago so yeah you know what actually
you could do that would make the
experience a little better is fly first
class I know that's what everyone says
too spend the extra money pamper
yourself first class you get the big
comfy seat to get someone kind of like
dedicated over you get to board first or
maybe you don't want a board work maybe
you board last year oh yeah yeah so on
the plane less time I think what I like
is one of those rooms but they don't
have those domestically no they don't
but if I could have that I would have my
own space so if I freak out and just
like feel like I'm dying I can just do
that myself and some La show wants me to
come on some Daytime ABC The Talk The
Talk The Talk wants you on yeah isn't
that the one with uh what's her name
I've never heard of the show I'm
thinking over Whoopi Goldberg
[Music]
you have to say I don't know what the
talk is I don't know what the talk is
either but they want me to do like a
live off in someone it could be fun I've
never been to La yeah I would take the
opportunities because you don't know if
they're going to be around forever and
you don't want to be 20 years from now
looking back then I wish I had done that
but I was too afraid to take the chance
to do it a billion what's your biggest
insecurity maybe the thickness really I
I want to say I'm not knowingly insecure
about many things my friends might be
able to tell me I'm insecure about
things that I'm not aware of
maybe the thickness just because there's
nothing else I can think of
thick
lumps and what about your insecurity of
internal things
is it mostly what we've discussed thus
far yeah I guess if I had a partner I'd
be you know they would need to be like
aware of my anxiety issues and I'd be
nervous about the first time anything
anxiety would happen around someone I'd
be nervous I was nervous about that with
you guys today like I was like nervous I
wouldn't be able to sleep last night
because I was excited uh so then all of
a sudden you know less sleep you get
more anxious panic attack who knows so
yeah I guess that could be an insecurity
I think meditation it sounds like you
overthink and over analyze I'm very much
the same way I think if you calm your
mind you find other things that you
could focus on or the gym
for me has been a lifesaver it's been
amazing finding Outlets like that that
relieves so much stress reading is great
too I love audiobooks let's see I feel
unproductive when I'm physically reading
for some reason the problem with
audiobooks is the fact that your brain
can Trail elsewhere whereas if you're
actually reading text on a page you
can't really be reading and
understanding and like drawing
information from there I'm just
convincing you're wasting time I know
I'm not but I'm convinced I'm wasting
time when I'm reading so what I do
audiobooks or YouTube videos to X speed
while I'm at the gym yeah or on the
treadmill and I watch I watch all my
YouTube videos on the treadmill or I
make my phone calls in the truck yeah
where you call me because every time
yeah
I make all my calls in the treadmill and
then when I look down at the calories
I'm like oh wow I just burned 70
calories on the phone with you yeah and
then you didn't even convince me to rent
and it didn't work well
I wish you did but imagine imagine it
you could do something productive while
burning calories at the same time no
it's like you're you're doubling your
output I finally when I was I was using
my elliptical
um
maybe like three months ago for a good
while I got down to a pretty okay wait
that I was chilling with and I went up
since then but
for the first time in my life I got the
runners High never knew what that was
and I thought it was always but
I was like oh after like 10 minutes
of hating this all of a sudden I was
like whoo
you got the Zone things I was just in
the dry just wanted to keep going yeah
it was fun so I know I need to get back
to that I've allowed the move to be an
excuse to go backwards if I pull up my
uh cardio uh uh whatever the cardio
level is cardiovascular whatever
uh you'll see when I moved in because it
went so
yeah that's something I need to get back
to for sure and I need to start that I
hope this conversation is hopefully a
good motivator to do that and you're
also talking about potentially doing
other shows in your channel yeah yeah
what do you want to do nervous to say it
why because I don't want anyone else to
do no one's going to be able to do it
like fine I'll do the ones I'll say the
ones that people already know I want to
bring back a good version of dating
money we did test versions We didn't
know what we were doing but that was
perfect I'm glad we did that because we
learned what worked and what didn't work
yeah and we have this whole Grand idea
around it that is like 10 times better I
want to do that it'd be fun it'll be
funny it'll be engaging I want to bring
back audit on the street where I audit
random people on the street I want to
bring back dumb money where someone can
email in a situation and like what
should I do around that and then get
random people's suggestions on that and
then give my suggestion so I want to
bring back some of the classics on like
a second Channel
um doing a grocery shopping trip you
know 300 grocery budget yeah
um or whatever that is broken down on a
weekly basis because I guess we'll shop
for a week but
there's a few on their secret secret
shows that we talked about earlier I
want to see you on a first date
that's what I want to see I have the
date sitting right where I'm sitting and
you guys talk Finance Finance yes yeah
I'm usually a little uh
some sometimes I'm awkward on a first
date and sometimes I'm better well and
and sometimes I'm like
like I'm the guy like you know what does
that the guy look like to you like when
you are being the guy how does that how
is that
like you're just smooth or like what is
interesting yeah smooth hitting every
word nailing it engaging that
conversation and what is the determinant
of whether or not you are that guy I
walk away feeling like the guy like what
determines you know whether or not
you're the guy or not no idea walk away
with it feeling good no but you walk
away but how do you go in how do I feel
good like how do I get a guy yeah what
do you want with the guy like what
determines if today you're gonna be the
guy or not yeah is it good sleep outfit
on point
is it arbitrary I don't really care
about what I wear usually so uh yeah I
guess it's pretty arbitrary I don't know
conversations are nailed dude sometimes
I think you just wake up and you're like
today is going to be a good day I'm on
it today that's how I feel I'm like
today is a good filming day
yeah speaking on that I know you do h m
and I was all h m so this is Express
which is a pretty well at least for me
it's an expensive place get a friend who
works at a clothing place and get
yourself it's 50 discount then it's
basically h m but nicer hmm I prefer
Zara oh okay still a little expensive
though yeah yeah I guess so slightly I
just don't like spending money on
clothes I don't know I feel like there's
things my entire outfit's free yeah he
gets all of his clothes for free yeah no
I guess I can't beat that it's very very
expensive yeah that's his favorite thing
I forget what this is
um speaking of the thickness I don't
know if Graham's gonna allow this but
Graham called himself fat earlier I said
a little pudgy I have a little stomach
no you said that you mentioned some
thickness this is thickness that is not
something we need to worry about I I
would like is that your biggest
insecurity
uh I would say so I I don't like taking
my shirt off because I see pudge
around my midsection and I really don't
like it and I want like just I want that
rock hard I want to get back into the
boxing uh I didn't even have that with
the boxing oh no and I and I dyed it
pretty pretty strict on that part of me
thinks it's a bit of an age thing but I
have to take I have to take it so
seriously like I've been going to the
gym every day I've been eating
relatively clean and then I'm thinking
it's probably my portions
scary maybe not staying hydrated you've
passed it you're at that 33 but that big
3-0 but you see some people in their 40s
they're like I'm in my best shape in my
life and they were like just ripped and
shredded dude my parents like great I
don't know what's going on with them but
I feel like I'm like dying yeah so
I've lost track of this what do you
think is the meaning of life kill Hammer
me in my life right now is helping
people while having fun doing it that's
what I like doing that's the mean in my
life right now
yeah meaning of life happiness isn't
that what everyone says I don't know
I don't know I'm a day-to-day kind of
guy I got goals but I'm a day-to-day guy
and the guy I can get it through the day
try not to you know get hit by a car and
what do you want to say to all the
haters
haters what do you say to them
it's a Death Note
the what I say to haters uh
boo you
haters
all right is there anything else you
want to discuss comments concerns
anything for us you can ask us questions
can we give you dinner
are we gonna eat dinner I can be down
for dinner I hope you guys have enjoyed
this episode I know it is a highly
anticipated iced coffee Hour episode
everyone wants Caleb on uh we're really
excited to be doing this and I hope you
guys enjoyed and let us know if you guys
want a part two maybe just maybe in this
part too we can discuss Caleb's
transformation okay he's gonna have a
six-pack he's gonna be ripped okay he's
gonna have like a huge neck vein right
here and uh yeah it's gonna be sick
we're gonna put your face on liver King
yeah you should see my jawline when I'm
fit dude it's hot it's gnarly you do
have a pretty gnarly jawline I know and
this is surrounded by fat but you're
also kind of shaping your beard you know
what I mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you look good
man all right guys thank you so much for
watching till next time